okay well in Rebecca's first slide she
presented what I was planning to say
which the issues that we have our
diverse locations heterogeneous data and
lack of software tools but since I have
half an hour I'll say it again okay and
first of all by background I wouldn't
say I'm a trained computer scientist but
we can get into that but I'm a computer
scientist and my view of computer
sciences we are toolmakers
and so my goal here is like what tools
do you need I think Rebecca referenced
you know continually looking for
available tools no no no go out and
specify the tools you need and where
that's what we live for is new problems
and I also want to make a point about
machine vision machine learning machines
do not see machines do not learn people
do and we're making tools to us to
extend what people can see and extend
what people can learn and what I wanted
to talk about is what I
I mean there's all this great promise I
mean you're reading all the stuff that
AI and so forth is gonna make happen
like what what's standing in the way in
my view is a lack of data particularly
the some kinds of data not quantity and
and the lack of tools so I just wanted
to present a few thoughts along these
lines and I thought I'd start by ripping
from today's headlines what one one
long-term project that I work on fits
and starts is learning about stone
weathering from the point of view of
computer graphics how to make realistic
models and from the point of view of
conservation what are the mechanisms how
can we avoid it and so one thought for
many years is you know we can get
pictures and scans of objects today and
these are you know sculptures from notre
dam and and we can see all of the stone
loss that there there is and we can
estimate the shapes and so forth of
these and we can learn something a
the stone weathering process by looking
at historic photos are the same things
monuments of this sort people have been
taking photos of but it turns out to be
really difficult to get photos and
reliable photos even though there should
be collections we can see from the ones
we find that there's been tremendous
loss this is an image from a postcard
that was for sale so unless I wanted to
cough up the money to buy it I have no
idea where this was taken and when it
was taken
useful pieces of data that you need if
we want to conduct this kind of study
this one's really weird it's from a
poster that Walmart's selling that is
based on an old postcard so it really
have lost where it came from but what's
interesting is there's not as much loss
here so like we're on the building is
this why is their last loss and then
like aha here I have a picture that is
from the Yale visual collection I must
have all the data about that I can
finally know like where was this taken
when was it taken well it probably
wasn't taken and the published created
date of 1222 1240 so I don't I don't
know you know if there's no information
on the postcard if this was what was on
the reverse or if somebody just assumed
that when people looking through the
visual collection they were interested
in the Cathedral rather than stone
weathering so all the all the sort of
missing data that either wasn't entered
or if somebody had it now can't enter
right now because this is a fixed asset
to a more successful project from a
colleague in France who's studied Notre
Dame a great deal he still he has
studied these kings in front which of
course and the theme of we've been
losing Notre Dame for a long time these
are not the original Kings the original
Kings were removed and beheaded in the
not kidding they they took down the
kings of the stone sculptures of the
Kings from Notre Dame and and publicly
beheaded them in the French Revolution
and only in 1977 the heads were found in
in the back of somebody's house anyway
so what he did was studied the heads and
and the remains in the in the Cathedral
which they have also 3d scanned there's
been a lot of news media about the guy
at Vassar and and and Assassin's Creed
and other people who've but you know
obviously the French have also anyway he
examined remnants of colors on the heads
and on the structure so bringing
together this theme of bringing you
having to bring together lots of sources
just like you have lots of sources yet
this purple flower but there's all this
stuff you've got to bring together and
he also brought together imagery of how
the light changes on the front of the
cathedral at sunset and did some
hypotheses of what the cathedral
actually looked like in medieval times
so at the point here being you know that
the learning requires assembling
heterogeneous data sets from many
locations so with those themes I just
wanted to talk about you know three
aspects here using 3d 2d and and
organizing collections and I realized I
don't have the time here so would you do
do this okay so and in 3d I mean so four
you know and as far as computer vision
for thirty years I probably you say
forty we've had all this research on how
to do active scanning and and
photogrammetry and you know these are
projects I've been involved in and of
course there's been thousands and
thousands all over the world in in
capturing 3d of cultural heritage and
and and Natural History collections and
these are a good for some individual
studies like these are studies of of one
of Michelangelo's pietà is how was it
meant to be viewed what did it look like
when Michelangelo broke it apart
before it was repaired these are from
the Egyptian Museum in Cairo how are
these objects used
and here from a that we did at Yale a
special exhibit that brought together
many busts of the poet of Alexander Pope
by the same artistry Billy ACK scanning
all these to compare how the
representation changed over time I
should say the Smithsonian has
spectacular 3d scans and particularly I
was taken by this one this is enormous
Lee technically difficult must have been
to challenge and incredibly informative
it's the the inside of Apollo 11 which
you know I hopefully everybody will
visit this year and on the anniversary
and it's got great data about it
including this little nugget about
astronaut graffiti that I wish they said
more about I'd like like buzzes whatever
I wouldn't they what do you mean
astronaut graffiti so also I went yes
there was a later talk is activating an
artwork at the Hirshhorn
I don't know if people that hurt her and
realized that this sculptor by Ferren in
inspired a graduate student named Cindy
girl to start a whole line of computer
graphics research for that well that
goes on today in a forum in so called
global illumination and this is the
Hurons official picture of it which is
pretty good but you know she had this
one taken to emphasize this lighting
effect that was the inspiration that and
that so there was a model built to show
this is in 1980 or so how well we could
have simulated the lighting on this and
by the end of the eighties the
improvements in lighting algorithms so
another modeling little anecdote that's
associated with the work at the
Smithsonian anyway so there's a lot of
examples of scanning I mean like
thousands and thousands are scanning for
documentation scanning for public
communication but not that much what
have we really learned what kind of
analysis that we do that gives us new
insights into the past from these so a
group of us got together to sort of
review the literature and find out
particularly with respect to geometry
that's
3d scanning about what have people
actually learned and we developed a
taxonomy for this as far as numbers of
objects scale of objects types of
application I won't bore you with the
whole thing but most of it is either
improving legibility or doing
restoration is what people have done so
far so making tablets can they afford
and so forth easier to read reassembling
broken pieces this is from Benedict
Browns work when back when he was at
Princeton but putting together in this
case frescoes that's another case of
Irish tax documents that were damaged in
the fire and that were we have scanned
with with photogrammetry so that they
can be digitally flattened and read this
is from University of Kentucky where
they do
catskil and volumetric scanning of
fragile documents so that you can
virtually unroll and read them and then
there's a lot of projects which borrow
from fairly standard engineering and and
other aerial survey techniques to do
things like monitoring of historic
structures or in this case the same sort
of thing you might do for like crop
management or enemy surveillance using
aerial data to understand usage patterns
so a lot of work that involves basically
a single object we haven't seen much
with collections this is a little bit of
work on that line we're looking at sets
of coins and finding the same figure
across several coins that were found
this is another studying the faces on
the banyan temple in in Cambodia with
the goal immediately as the immediate
goal of trying to do restorations this
is one true collections that
where these are figures 3d scanned at
the Louvre to try to determine
provenance for four pieces that you know
that the their origins aren't known and
this is a study of a smaller collection
of busts of Augustus that were done to
try to find the relationship of when
when the bus were done and by whom but
overall in our whole survey taxonomy the
the the collection analysis which it's
just like but the big thing we can do
but yet to do things at scale it's it's
it's a very empty space right now so
what is the problem why aren't we doing
more about bringing objects from from
different museums together and doing
these collection analysis and I think
there's two things that we have a lot of
very small collections that are
scattered geographically and they are
often lacking contextual data that would
make them useful I mean this virtual
curation lab which shows up on sketchfab
and if you're not like sort of a
computer game builder you probably don't
use this site much but it's where people
Park a lot of computer models because
you can and it takes a lot of effort to
build this side that this assailant
virginia commonwealth university but the
models there from the most part they are
simplified from what they were
originally scanned because you know just
so that they can be displayable at home
and there's very little contextual data
and it's it's kind of a smattering of
stuff from all over it's not apples to
apples kinds of studies that we want to
do CyArk which for many years has been
going around the world doing large-scale
scanning of structures has made all of
their data open now so there's dozens
and dozens of sites ranging from huts
and Antarctica to cathedrals to Cape
Canaveral so a lot of diverse places and
there's no lack
of quantity of data there's gigabytes
and gigabytes and gigabytes but you know
it's still like it's not clear how can
we make use of this what do we need is
it just managing the sheer volume I
think we also need contextual data that
goes with it to understand what we're
trying to study what questions were
answering just shifting then from 3d to
2d where obviously there's been a lot
more success because it's one less D so
like for example we've had worked here
in studying medieval manuscripts where a
lot of work has been you know it's the
same thing there's many manuscripts in
many different places so viewers have
been built that can take you know and
and standard representations so that you
can take manuscript pages from many
different sources and read and compare
them this is work from mainly from
Stanford in collaboration with you on
our side we did some various test cases
to illustrate studying large quantities
of pages both their layout and their
their spectral reflectance the layout is
of interest to identify things ahead of
time sort of adding data to things so
that subsequently when people want to
ask questions it's easy to access the
results and so it's layout not so much
the the words I mean these are from
books of ours I mean they're prayer
books everybody knows what they said
that was kind of the point of them but
what's interesting is the different ways
that they are laid out and spotting
things like these I don't have a arrow
either here these little these little
bars that indicate that this is his
poetry as opposed to the the main text
so we did a lot of work you know
consistently identifying layout across
and the challenges and in these
manuscripts being lots of damage and
things missing and variety of that sort
of thing we also did a study of the
apparent color of pigments to understand
changes that may indicate
things being made by different people in
different places we did this doing
hyperspectral imaging I won't go into
that as opposed to regular RGB cameras
and what was interesting there is like
oh great these things look different and
now not only they do they look different
I have different pots that are
associated with them and it's still like
and so what so is that a significant
difference or not a significant
difference so we go on with the analysis
to do things like go through thousands
of pages and cluster the colors to count
the colors and then see what is the
spectral variation within pages to
understand what's a normal distribution
of color variations as opposed to
something that indicates some sort of
change in authorship or manufacture
another sort of long-term thing that's
bugged me I haven't made much progress
on is you know like the Google arts and
culture they're thousands and thousands
of high-resolution images like what can
we do with them what is anybody doing
with them what is so one thing is
studying crack patterns in the paintings
to understand where the cracks came from
what can we do about them and if you're
lucky and and on Rembrandt's face or his
hat you have light paint you can you can
sort of see them although even here
extracting them reliably with image
processing is is difficult and so I've
never really had had various students
start on this and get frustrated a
brilliant idea that Lukesh brought us
who and who recently was at the Yale IP
CH and is now running a an analysis lab
in Poland working with with the Yale
Center for British art is this idea of
using x-rays of the images rather than
just trying to see the cracks on the
images so there's an x-ray and you have
to see it close-up okay that the cracks
are harder to see but there's a lot less
in the way of them as far as dark paint
light paint so we have a chance to
extract the cracks from the x-ray and
then
learn using deep learning the
relationship between those cracks and
the appearance of the paintings so that
then once we learned that we can
probably at least to some extent detect
cracks in paintings that we don't have
the x-rays for it's not it's not a
slam-dunk there's a lot of work to do
but it's it's a great idea that that
we'll be pursuing on the last topic I
wanted to touch on which which was
already mentioned is this problem of
heterogeneous data you've got all sorts
of information and this is similar to I
think the last couple of projects you
were talking about so I think we may
have some overlap in tools we might want
to develop this is a Elihu Rubin from
the School of Architecture has developed
this over many years through a course he
teaches where students document details
of buildings in New Haven the idea is
like history's not just the great
person's the the famous buildings but
it's it's our communities it's where we
live in our where we live is is New
Haven so documenting the individual
buildings and New Haven this is
something that cyma actor who's here
it's been working on as well as as
Benedict
so in this archive the each students
responsible for finding as much as they
can that includes maps from the library
it includes scans of of permit
applications for for changes in the
building lists of who occupied it
through time just every every little you
know scrap of paper associated with
transactions historic photos stories
social history so that we're getting
this database of of New Haven so then
the question is now we're getting this
great heterogeneous database what kind
of studies can we do and what tools
would be needed to go across this corpus
of images and texts so that's what I
wanted to bring up with sort of these
ideas like why aren't we using 3d we
need context where did the data come
from
and more things like you know what was
the date of the postcard and so forth
and 2d this enhancing the data with with
new correlations from from labeled
samples and just our new tools for
learning from heterogeneous data
[Applause]
[Music]